now at 7 30 on cbs mornings with a
potential medical breakthrough involving
an infant boy from north carolina that
could eventually benefit millions of
people the boy easton cinnamon was born
with a congenital heart defect and a
non-functioning immune system but in a
medical first surgeons at duke
university saved his life by performing
a heart transplant surgery
and boosting his immune system at the
same time omar villafranca shows us how
this combination of procedures could
potentially help other organ transplant
patients worldwide
easton cinnamon hasn't taken his first
steps but his parents caitlin and
brandon say he's already been on the
journey of a lifetime when we found out
that we were having a boy we also found
out about his heart defect easton was
born with a serious congenital heart
condition that left him with half of a
functioning heart at only five days old
doctors performed open heart surgery to
fix the aorta and a leaking valve in his
little heart a few days later easton
survived a life-threatening cardiac
arrest we actually had the conversation
of he was put here for a reason and that
reason we don't know
maybe he was here to be a donor for
another child
we were having that conversation you
know a few months after another heart
procedure was unsuccessful
easton needed a new heart and was put on
the transplant list but blood tests
revealed another problem his immune
system was not working and he needed a
new thymus dr joseph turek is the chief
of pediatric cardiac surgery at duke
university and is easton's doctor the
thymus is part of your immune system and
it makes t cells that t cells can be
good they fight infection but they can
also be bad in the sense that they will
reject an organ transplanting a heart
and implanting cultured thymus tissue
grown in a lab from the same donor had
never been performed together before
amazingly easton was at the very
hospital that had been studying that
type of procedure for decades this
doesn't happen very often where you can
you'll be working on something in the
laboratory and it has direct translation
and could help a patient
that you're taking care of doctors had
to get fda authorization for the surgery
and after consulting with physicians the
cinnamons agreed to the first of its
kind surgery after 112 days on the
transplant waiting list a heart became
available in august of 2021 the way that
it was put to us is is if it doesn't
work you're going to be on the same path
you're going to be on a transplant
anyway and if it does work and if it
does work you can change the world
that's because organ recipients face
unique challenges the immune system t
cells made in the thymus could reject a
new organ to prevent that from happening
recipients have to take anti-rejection
medicines which can have harsh side
effects for patients duke researchers
say by transplanting both a solid organ
and cultured thymus tissue from the same
donor it could potentially eliminate the
need for anti-rejection medicine
transplanted hearts currently last about
10 to 15 years the hope is to extend
that significantly potentially up to 40
years this could apply to
any organ any solid organ transplant
that we do when you hear that it's a
broad
broad group of people that could benefit
i mean that is a
millions yeah
yeah absolutely
eight months after making medical
history easton is finally home with mom
dad and his big sister ivy
i like to hold him and play with him
when we first brought him home in
september he couldn't hold his head up
he couldn't sit up on his own and now
he's dancing in his chair and walking
around the house in his walker chasing
his sister the cinnamons are now focused
on making memories as a family for cbs
mornings omar villafranca ramser north
carolina
oh man uh little easton is so adorable
but i'm in awe of dr turek and the
researchers at duke i mean i was
thinking that too
i was just a
doctor yeah science medicine such it's
it's a great outcome it's hard to see a
little baby i remember teddy was in the
uh uh i see you for a while with a fever
and
all the wires are on stuff
bravo